which is that I think there's a really
interesting question here it's one of
the things that that's worth analyzing
and I know that the recent others have
analyzed it but you see I think what's
interesting and I say this is someone
who's become a Catholic in Stanley right
but I will you know the Protestant
religion which grew out of a sense that
the Catholic Church had lost its way
that the Christian religion had departed
from any proper obedience to its
teaching also had within it of course
really quite a revolutionary notion
which is which is a very reforming
notion which is that the the values of
Christianity had to be extracted from
all their doctrine and dogma and panoply
in ceremony and all the rest of it and
applied to the world in which people
were actually living you know so it is
quite interesting that which then
informed of course i mean the the the
civil war in England English revolution
and so on fact one of the oddest things
are found in the Gregory Clark bit was
this notion that poor had lived in
instabilities as the Year 1200 you know
actually no we went through many
processes of you know internal wars in
the United Kingdom and religious battles
and so on and so forth but the spirit
that came out of that was one that very
much informed liberal democracy and I
think one of the issues that's most
fascinating in the world today is what
prompts religious evolution I mean one
of the things I was saying in my points
was there is an evolution of religious
though
odd and actually most faiths have gone
through an evolutionary process what
prompts it what are the factors that
give give rise to that redefinition you
know actually if you look at work i
think that is being done i think i'm
right in turkey today which is about
reinterpretation and various hadith from
islam which is really starting to say
well look how do we how do we you know
given that the the the holy book was
from the seventh century how do we then
you know reinterpret for what is the
21st century world now i think that
process of change what prompted what
gives rise to it what underpins it what
drives it what then allows it to start
shaping that the socio-economic and
political forces is a really interesting
question because actually you know if
you look at for example some of the
hindu fundamentalism in india right now
a lot of it is obviously to do with a
certain degree of identification often
against Christianity or Islam but it's
also born out of a failure in certain
aspects for this process of reform and
evolution and modernization to take
effect and route and it's a really
interesting thing every single religion
around the world is facing that
challenge today so we really do have to
sort of break it up now but i think you
know just leave you with this thought
before our next because we will get to
know each other well over over the
coming few months i didn't just give you
a sense of why i think this is this is
so important i I actually do believe
that the issue that we're discussing is
the thing we will have to make sense of
and learn about and get right for the
21st century to function and and one way
of doing that is is to examine the issue
in all its different aspect because when
you start to surface things
and put them out there and subject them
to analysis and research and debate and
publication around that then you know
you start to get some solutions coming
forward and you know I often think of it
with with because I offer to have this
conversation with friends of mine who
are who are priests or clerics and I say
to them because I read a lot about and
religion I mean particularly but not
limited to Christianity and you know I
always say to them you guys you have a
relationship with your public that is
often less than frank about all the
things you know and have learned about
your own religion and you're often
worried to explain all the things that
you know and what you've learned and
studied in case you discomfort or even
somewhat dislocate your your your
congregation by talking about historical
context and how doctrines came about and
how things developed and so on and I
think one of the really important things
if we're going to make sense of the
world of faith and globalization is to
encourage the outside world to look
inside the world of religion and
discover it discovering both its
strengths and its weaknesses and it's
courage and its frailty and I think it's
a really important thing for us to do
because when we come in from the outside
and look at that world actually there's
no reason to be frightened of it I don't
think if you are someone at faith on the
contrary I think when people from the
outside come in and look it forces you
to re-evaluate what it is you're really
about
just as a person of faith presume of
being and in that process of revaluation
you can often reach a commitment that is
both deeper and certainly more effective
in terms of how it can change the world